[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another got user
interface tutorial today we're going to
be focusing on making a basic animation
component so that we can animate our
control nodes just a little bit easier
as always you can grab the source files
for everything that we're doing on my
patreon otherwise let's get going we're
going to be creating sort of an
interface a component setup to add
animations a lot easier than creating a
script for every single node that we
want to animate and by doing this we're
going to learn a little bit more about
how these control nodes are working and
also about tween which is a really quick
way to add animation uh with G scripts
so what we need to do is to create a new
class let's go ahead and create a new
folder here and we'll call this scripts
and we'll create a new script now this
script is going to be called the
animation
components and it's where we're going to
create our new class if you've not
created a a class before when you add a
node these are basically well these
aren't basically these are classes
that's what these are and you can extend
these classes with your own classes or
create your own what we're going to do
is extend uh node because we don't need
anything fancy and we're going to create
a new class we do that by doing class
name and then the name of our class
which will be an animation component now
if I save that already if I go to my
create new node and I type in animation
component it's already there we can
already add that to our seam in fact
let's go ahead and do that so the idea
behind a component is that instead of
going into our our button here and
adding a new script I can simply take an
animation component make it a child of
that button and it's going to affect how
that button operates I don't have to do
anything to the button it's just adding
the component that's all you need to do
now I've added it as a child but
obviously it's not going to do anything
because we don't have any code we have
no scripts what we're going to do is
we're going to add a few export
variables we need to have some things
that we want to change and adjust so we
can alter them whenever we load this
component the first one will be a from
Center Boolean and we'll get into that
in a minute basically the uh the way
these buttons
operate is the origin point in fact you
can see it right here the origin point
is up here in the top left now if we I
don't think I can do it by hand but if I
were to scale it no I can't do it by
hand that's another point in fact let's
go ahead and talk about that real quick
when you have a control node that is a
child of a container the container
controls the transform it controls the
size it controls position rotation scale
all that stuff now you can't change it
in the inspector but you can change it
in code so that's important to note so
by by adding an export variable to uh
make it from Center what we're what
we're going to do is we're going to move
this origin Point um right there so when
we scale it it doesn't scale from the
top left scales from the middle so we'll
have that export uh from Center and then
we'll have another export for the hover
scale that is how much we want to scale
it when we hover we're just going to add
a uh a scaling animation for our example
in this video and then another export
variable for time and that is going to
be how long that animation is supposed
to take and then another export variable
for our transition type we'll leave that
we'll leave that there for now and we'll
get back to that when we look at Twins
and it's unhappy about my vector I
didn't add a two a vector vector means
nothing Vector two means something so
transition type let's comment that out
we'll come back to that because I don't
want to jump into why we need that just
yet all right then we need a couple of
variables here and that's going to be
Target so the target is going to be the
node that we want to alter we're going
to animate a node the target is that
node and the parent the node that is the
the parent of our component that's going
to be our Target so we're going to set
the target to our parent and then we
need to get a default
scale to return to okay so those are the
variables that we need so in our ready
function what we're going to do first is
set our Target variable and our Target
variable will be get parent so already
we have a reference to the node that we
we put our component into and we don't
need our process function and next I'm
going to create the the twe functions
that we need the animation functions um
so first I need two different functions
one for when we hover onto the button
and one when we hover off of the button
so I'll make a function on
Hover we will Avid that because we're
not returning anything in this function
and we're going to be
adding a tween in here once we create
that tween then we need another function
called off
hover we'll void that and pass
that and then let's create the uh the
function for our tween this is where the
magic will happen so we'll add a
function called add tween now within
this we're going to need a couple of
parameters the first will be what
property we want to animate
then the value that we want to animate
to and then uh how long that animation
is how long we want to take to get to
that
value and then we will void that now
within this we're going to create a
tween and the process to do that is to
do
tween create a variable to put the tween
in get
tree and then create tween so now we've
created a tween it's in our variable
called tween and now we need to tell it
what property we want to actually
animate so we do tween then tween
property and then we need the object
that we want to animate so in this case
that's the parent that's what we've
added to as our targets so we set it to
targets then we want to animate our
property that we set and then our value
then the value that we want to go to
and then how long we want that animation
to take so that's the the tween property
function that's what it needs it needs
what am I animating what property am I
animating what am I animating it to
what's the value and then how long
should that animation take and then the
final part that we can add to
this is a set transition now this is
where the transition type up here is
going to come into so we've created our
export variable transition type we're
going to plug that into
here and we need this to actually equal
something so within this set
transition there is a setting for the
tween transition type and this
transition type is a a numeration and
there are all of these different
transitions that you can use and uh
different values in fact there's a cheat
sheet for these transitions that I'll
put in the description so you can check
them out on the um the g website now in
order to get those enumerations into our
export what we can do is use tween and
then transition type as the type now if
we save that you'll notice over here in
our transition type export now we've got
a drop down and that dropdown contains
all of the different transition types
that we can pick we don't have to create
our own enumeration we don't have to
list out manually and it's going to take
that value and load it into our set
transition and it's going to work great
all right now that we have set up our ad
tween let's go back to our on Hover
we're going to call that function add
tween and our property that we want to
adjust is our scale we want to adjust it
to our hover scale using the time that
we set we'll do the same thing when we
hover off I don't know if there's a
better way to say off hover un
hover we'll animate the
scale now the value here we we don't
actually have the default value we need
to save that which we're going to do
that in a second but let's go ahead and
put
in default scale and then the the time
that we wanted to animate now we have a
function to animate create a tween to
scale it up and scale it down when we
hover and un hover now we have two
things that we need to set up yet in
order for this to work the first is we
don't know if we're actually hovering or
or not hovering because that information
comes from the parent it comes from our
button and it comes from these signals
over here it comes from Mouse entered
Mouse exited our script has no idea when
those are are happening or when those
are occurring so we need to set those up
and then the other thing that we need to
fix is our our Center issue and we need
to set our default scale so let's do our
setup
first we'll create a new function here
and we'll call it
setup we will void that so the first
thing is our our from Center so if from
Center meaning if we want to um consider
the origin as the center of our object
then we want to take the uh pivot offset
which is a setting within our button
here in fact if I go into the transform
it's right here
we want to take that pivot offset and we
want to set it to the Target size so the
size of our Target in this case it's
300X 63 and we want to divide that by
two and that's going to give us the
middle point of our
button and then the next thing we need
to do is set our default scale to
equal the current scale of our Target
what this will do is fix our Center
issue
and it's going to save the the scale
that the button is when we load when we
first load that button it's going to
save that as the default scale so we can
load it later on so we've got that now
we need to run this actually in a weird
way and it basically has to do with I I
believe a process of of loading how
these load if I just run this function
this setup function this uh pivot
offset's going to be off it's not going
to be right and I think it has to do
with the the button hasn't scaled um to
its size transform based on on how these
are loading within the tree uh if you
don't understand what that is it it's
don't worry about it it's uh not
important because we're going to fix it
so what we need to do is we need to we
need to run that setup function like
very very last after everything is
loaded so we can do that by using what
is called the call deferred function now
what this does is it runs whatever uh
method we put in
here when uh everything else is done
loading like when there's a pause when
there's the frame is done which is what
we want because when everything's done
it means everything is loaded so we're
going to do that we're going to run
setup um within our called deferred
function and that's going to fix this
pivot offset issue the last thing we
need to do is to fix our signal issue
now what we
do is we can make connections in fact
let's make a let's make a function we're
going to call it make
connections which is actually that's
pretty unclear uh let's call it uh
connect signals that's better we're
going to connect these two signals this
mouse entered and mouse exited to our
onhover and off hover so we can do that
by getting the targets getting our Mouse
entered
signal connecting it and then connecting
it to on Hover and we do the same thing
for Mouse
exited connect it to off hover now you
don't want the parentheses in there you
just want the name of the callable all
right so now we've connected our signals
we need to run
that in our get ready function and we
should be we should be good to go so
let's set up a an animation now we've
got a hover scale of let's say 1.5 1.1
let's make it take that's that's too
long let's make it take5 seconds and
let's do the uh transition back all
right we'll save that and then we'll
test test our scene and there you go so
just like that we've created an
animation for our hover on Hover off and
we can customize the uh the nature of
that animation pretty easily and if we
wanted to animate our second button over
here we can do just that so we can add a
new animation component to our button
let's do our
settings do a little bit faster maybe
how about a elastic now this will be a
different animation than the first
animation we did there's our first
there's our second one pretty cool now
this can be I think expanded to um you
know entry animations exit animations a
whole bunch of different animation types
and uh I've got an idea about how to
control that in a pretty easy way so
we'll keep building on this in the next
couple of videos and hopefully we'll
have a a nice animation system that we
can use as we create our user interfaces
going forward that's it for this one
thanks for watching and as always keep
creating all right guys if this tutorial
was helpful consider it a like And
subscribe to the channel as we're going
to be covering a lot more thanks to all
of my patrons who keep the series going
you too can get access to the project
source files by joining my patreon you
can download everything there and you'll
also get early access to my videos and
sneak peeks at Future tutorials thanks
for watching and as always keep creating
[Music]
oh